if you really want to hear about just
the worst of the worst of the left you
have to hear about what's happening
over the last 72 hours now last week i
got a phone call during live calls on
last
friday show from a viewer asking me what
do i think about the aoc
versus jimmy dore debate and when the
caller asked me about it i had no idea
what it was about and the caller
explained to me very very politely the
debate is that a youtuber named jimmy
door
thinks that the squad should hold their
votes for nancy pelosi's uh
speaker of speakership hostage unless
nancy pelosi is willing to hold a vote
in the house for medicare for all
and when the caller brought it up i
hadn't heard about it at the time
it started on twitter the previous
weekend i don't
watch the show that the caller mentioned
i wasn't on twitter over that weekend so
i had no idea
i have now learned about it thanks to
the caller
and the same thing continued to explode
this weekend where now
even aoc apparently isn't progressive
enough aoc is failing progressive purity
tests
because she's unsure about the value
of holding her vote hostage for a
medicare for all vote in the house she's
questioning whether that would really do
anything for people with acute needs
right now
now the funny thing about all of them
there's a bunch of funny things and some
sad things and some infuriating things
one of the funny things about this is
that for the last several years
when it comes to aoc i've mostly been
attacked
for being too critical of aoc and for
not being deferential enough
to any of aoc's notions when i found
that she lacked
knowledge or pragmatism in one place or
another i would mention it people would
be furious with me
now aoc is actually the one being
pragmatic
and the so-called populist left has
turned on her
and what's really bonkers is that the
populist left
seems more angry with aoc than they are
with donald trump
when trump is going lunatic
authoritarian uh and had an oval office
meeting uh over the weekend about
whether he should declare martial law if
he even could whether he should
seize voting machines by force because
he lost an election and he can't admit
it
but the populist left on twitter is
focused on aoc now in fact
i actually said about seven to eight
months after aoc was sworn in you know
guys i have to tell you
i am pleased that aoc's political
instincts
are maturing since she's gotten into
congress her political instincts
improved dramatically from the campaign
aoc
to when she was actually in office her
pragmatism
and her understanding of how politics
works improved dramatically
uh and now if you said to me right now
what is the most important thing to keep
in mind about this issue
what is the most instructive possible
takeaway
about this spat that is taking place
within the left
mostly on twitter and reddit well
there's actually a few takeaways number
one
there is nothing wrong with uh now i
want people to take out a notepad and
make a note of what i'm about to say
and don't email me about it okay because
i'm i'm telling you right now
there's nothing wrong with uh people on
the left criticizing others on the left
nothing wrong with them there's nothing
wrong with
uh progressives primary centrist or
corporate democrats that should be
that's great that should be encouraged
okay great
there's nothing wrong with any of those
things at a structural level
but the takeaways here are number one
the so-called populist left on twitter
and reddit represents a small
but very vocal internet enclave
that does not connect to most of what's
happening
in the real world now we learned this
sadly it was a rude awakening
during the democratic primary how could
bernie possibly have lost
he had so much energy he had the best
streams
he had the best rallies if you spent
time on twitter and read it
it looked like bernie couldn't possibly
have lost that primary
but he lost the primary by millions of
votes because most of the electorate
and the democratic party voters are not
in the internet populist left space
it's not a value judgment it's an
evaluation of fact
and if we don't get it it'll continue to
go this way
and this is the exact same thing if
you're a factory worker dad
who's trying to figure out how to put
food on your family's table
for your two kids while continuing to
work during a pandemic
and your employer might have to lay off
10 of the workforce due to the pandemic
and you might be in that 10
laid off do you need a list of the
members of congress who support medicare
for all right now
particularly absent any actual credible
way to get it passed as we are about to
get a new congress
seated i'm not saying the dad doesn't
care about medicaid medicare for all
i'm not saying that dad wouldn't benefit
from medicare for all i'm saying
does anyone outside of these online
spaces think that what is effectively a
naughty and nice list
in a congress that has two weeks left
before
some some leave and some new people get
sworn in that's what that dad cares
about
or imagine a business owner in houston
who sells
wedding dresses okay and has seen their
business decimated due to the stim due
to the
pandemic they're waiting on a second
stimulus they're wondering
when will people go back to weddings
that business owner is waiting on a vote
on medicare for all
which there is not even support for in
the senate anyway and which joe biden
didn't run on what
j just to have a list of people to
primary so the point
isn't that there's no place for such a
vote or that it shouldn't be done
i'm fine with it but attacking aoc
now because she's far more realistic
about how politics works than much of
the populace left when we're
we're trying to get a second stimulus it
looks like we're going to get a pathetic
one
uh and we have so many other issues
going on
and again the the president is talking
about martial law and seizing voting
machines
the the point is aoc now is not left
enough she's not past
the progressive purity test it's another
example of the left eating itself
if these people are even on the left i'm
not sure and that's what's tricky about
populist rhetoric
it sounds very similar on the left and
right until you get to the solutions
some of the so-called populist left now
attacking
aoc is praising tulsi gabbard
whose recent ideas on trans people and
abortion
don't look like anything i recognize as
being part of the left so
maybe the issue and i'm thinking out
loud here maybe the issue
is that some of these people aren't
really leftists they seem more into what
tucker carlson is proposing than what we
see from aoc
now again there are people who say i'm
not really on the left
so starting to to say well this person
is not really what they claim to be
i i get that it's fraught and that it's
problematic and my point
again just to restate it is not that the
left shouldn't criticize the left when
the left fails to be
left as i've done many times um but
uh the the real issue here is that it
seems to be a complete
loss of the plot for lack of a better
term
um trump considering martial law and
people are saying
aoc being unwilling to do something that
will make no political difference anyway
makes her enemy number one this is how
the left keeps losing i want the left to
win i don't think this is the path
to victory um let me know what you think
i would love to hear from you
remember that on january 1st we will
be doing a one-day membership special
the idea is to set the one-day record
for new memberships
as we've speculated my immoral illegal
membership specials could be clamped
down on by the incoming biden
administration so you gotta get those
memberships before biden is sworn in
that's that's a joke everybody relax
it's we're just kidding around
but in all seriousness on january 1st
we'll send out an email blast
with a monstrous membership special if
you want to be notified about it just
get on my mailing list
at davidpakman.com and let me know what
you think about this entire aoc thing
uh you can find me on twitter at dpakman